is that it oh no let me call it
dispatch is car two four we have visual
on unit five five looks abandoned over
copy that over
[ __ ] they're behind us forget it just go
now now dispatch this is car two four we
are open
what's going on out there this is
[Music]
rikers island is new york city's main
jail complex
the island is home to one of the world's
largest correctional facilities and
mental institutions
it has an average population of 10 000
inmates at any time
rikers has a reputation for abuse and
neglect and is ranked as one of the
worst correctional facilities in the
united states
following the outbreak of the green
poison prison guards stopped turning up
to work and a number of the ones who did
go in were sick with the virus
eventually medical support and supplies
were cut off from the island as the
general consensus from officials and the
public was that resources would be
better spent on the mainland
essentially the prisons were being left
to fend for themselves until the
situation on the mainland had been dealt
to
the inmate population was compiled of
various gang members
but given the situation they decided to
unite under a single leader and as one
unit they were able to organize and
escape from the island
it was lare who convinced the inmates to
all join forces as she managed to
convince them that together their
numbers would overpower their captors
and that if they didn't unite soon they
would be back under the thumb of the
government
larray barrett was imprisoned at rikers
island for double murder
she is treacherous ruthless and
unforgiving
she shows no remorse for her actions and
despises authority of any kind
you claim the officer put you in a
chokehold it ain't a claim that's a fact
and you felt it was appropriate to pull
the gun you had hidden on your person in
self-defense my client feared for her
life in shock to officers both family
men incidentally in the back of the head
execution style at point blank range
that is a curious kind of self-defense
you're smiling barrett something you
want to share just having me a nice
memory you know
childhood nothing to do with shooting
two innocent men in the back of the head
just puppies and baby dolls and flowers
and all that [ __ ] this is speculation
detective let's stick to the facts you
know i ain't nothing but sugar and spice
and everything nice
[Laughter]
the rumor floating around rikers was
that an administrator of the prison had
a bit of a thing for laurae and through
this relationship he organized a barge
so they could sail away into the sunset
together
however this relationship didn't last
long and as soon as the plane was set in
motion
larray cut the administrator's throat
and utilizing the barge she was able to
transport the prisoners to the mainland
you ain't no [ __ ] lieutenant man i
was right by her side [ __ ] owes me big
time do not let her hear you talk like
that fool you got a guest wish
how did you get past security hostages
barely any of those fool guards coming
to work since that [ __ ] hit the fan
rest of them sick or run off easy to
overpower them make them do what we
wanted then we watch them bleed like the
pigs they are some of those brothers
weren't so bad that's larae for you
where'd the [ __ ] barge come from you
know that stupid ass administrator had a
thing for her she got him to do it all
then just when he saw he was going to
ride off the glory with his outlaw woman
she slit his throat [ __ ]
she is one stone cold [ __ ] isn't she
larae had a very intimidating presence
and she often used brutal torture
methods on both captured jtf officers
and disobedient rikers
she needed a way of bringing her gang
members into line and these methods
proved the most effective for even the
most hardened criminal
many of her followers were afraid of her
and knew the dire consequences they
might face if they did not side with her
she controlled them by fear
if they weren't with her they were
against her and ultimately would meet
the same fate as the authority figures
she despised so much
once the rikers had established
themselves on the mainland they found
they had very little trouble with
expanding their numbers even further
as the local gangs heard about their
leader and their strength and many were
eager to join
unsurprisingly with this influx of new
recruits power struggles soon began to
follow
and larae further proved her
ruthlessness by swiftly dealing to those
who questioned her leadership
she proved that under her powerful
leadership that the rikers gang is not
to be messed with
when i was in rikers one of the girls
got a hold of this pen
stuck it right in the back of my head
so i took that pen and gave it right
back to her
and wouldn't you know it went straight
through her eye sliced open her cheek or
ink all over the inside of her mouth
but that wasn't enough
so i cut the bitch's throat
and after i finished stabbing her well
that was that point
i don't do second chances
[Music]
[Applause]
larae encouraged brutality towards the
jtf reminding her followers of the
government's plan to leave them all
behind to starve and die on rikers
island and because of this they must be
punished in the most horrific way
imaginable
we know them
they're the same under that uniform
police parole officers judges guards
child [ __ ] protection officers
fancy government agents with their fancy
ass watchers and these shiny guns
prancing around like they [ __ ] gods
or something
[Music]
they were gonna leave us to stop and die
in there
they don't give two shits about our
lives they never have and they never
will
we just some trash in their way they
just assume we just blow right away
but we gonna be a storm instead
gonna blow them to bits
these parasites and their shiny jtf
uniforms you know them you've been
dealing with them all your lives
all look the same on the inside well
let's see for ourselves shall we
yeah
that's what they look like on the inside
ugly
so you make them suffer you make them
big you make them do whatever the hell
you want
just make sure you don't leave anyone
alive
the rikers were getting creative with
their methods
they were making a statement
it was becoming a game a sport
their goal to take advantage of the
current situation in new york and claim
ownership for themselves
while slaughtering as many uniformed
authorities as possible
survival wasn't so easy on the mainland
a lot of the food and water had already
been pillaged by rioters and civilians
in need
fortunately for the wreckers the growing
rumors of le rey's brutality and
ruthlessness made it possible to secure
supplies for her members
yo this is larae what do you want from
me you know who i am
you know you can work for me or well
you don't have a lot of choices look
i got no beef with you okay
what do you want me to do good man
what i need you to do is simple
you haunt produce before you went on the
inside right yeah my people need food
you're gonna find that food and you're
gonna give it to the people of my
choosing you get it
i tell you when and where you keep it
running there ain't gonna be a lot left
get creative
find anything you can and bring it to me
[ __ ] this isn't gonna be easy
i'm gonna need trucks
and i'm gonna need drivers you'll have
them
deliveries start tomorrow you hear me
yeah
oh yeah i sure do
james dragoff's father was the head of a
russian crime family
he grew up around extortion bribery and
murder
he watched as a number of good people
turned bad
tainted by corruption and greed
their innocence lost
but dragoff chose a different path
the law
and became a new york police officer
however much to his dismay he found that
things weren't so different in the force
where egotism deceit and bribes were
abundant
so he made it his own personal mission
to dedicate his career in bringing down
the extortion and lies and put a stop to
it once and for all
dragof made a name for himself with his
stern and sharp shooting ways
he was beginning to accomplish changes
within his department on in-house crime
from here he began to get noticed by
recruiters
and not long after he was recruited by
the strategic homeland division
he was activated along with the first
wave division agents
but instead of assisting with the
quarantine in manhattan he was tasked
with helping the remaining correctional
officers on rikers island
the dollar flew had made it here too and
the dwindling guard presence due to
sickness meant that they required extra
support at this time
but as the virus spread through the city
prison riots began to get out of control
and communication to rikers island was
lost
before he was stationed on riker's
island dragoff was already starting to
show signs of frustration and of being
disenchanted with the division
the [ __ ]
how are this many agents assigned to
tribeca not really that surprising you
check who lives around here it's a who's
who of manhattan these people can get
out whenever they damn well please they
don't want to these families have never
faced adversity their biggest challenges
are deciding what country to import
their nannies from and which divorce and
immigration lawyers to hire so what
you're saying is
silver spoons and detached from reality
got it on the first try smarter than you
look i hope the division would be free
from this type of corruption nope
check that side of the street i think i
saw a movement roger that
in his eyes the twisted morals of his
crime family and the crooked police
force lies and manipulations had somehow
managed to creep its way into the
division ranks
he was beginning to realize even the
best of us can be turned and that
extortion is everywhere
money is power
the rich were being taken care of
while the poor were left struggling to
survive
on rikers island the prison warden had
made the call for all staff to leave the
island
this was the last straw for dragoff
what are you doing with the inmates well
they'll stay here you're leaving people
in lock up not everyone low-risk inmates
have already been released but the rest
will have to remain in their cells
it's for everyone's safety we can't
ensure their transition into society i'm
afraid i can't let you do that it's not
your call to make agent you have a
direct order to escort me off the island
my orders are to serve the people
it's a shame i got distracted doing my
job
and wasn't here in time to save you
wait
what are you doing
hey
no stop
dragoff killed the warden and freed the
prisoners
he wasn't prepared to just leave them
there to starve to death in their cells
he was marked as rogue but before he
left rucker's island he grabbed the
guard keys and handed them to larry
barrett
eventually enough was enough
the jtf found where larry barrett and
the rikers had set up camp and sent in
the division agents to take them down
the rikers were using the lexington
event centre as their hq
the jtf officers that found the hideout
were taken hostage so the first step was
to rescue the jtf and then shut down the
rikers by taking out la ray
immediately upon entering the events
centre it was obvious that this had been
used as an area to humiliate and torture
the jtf
it's just a little game of pin the axe
on the piggy how about
10 points if you get him in the arm
five for the hands what do you say 20
for the head
30.
depends on how deep it goes in
you know
that song the one about the bridge
damn
what is the name of that [ __ ]
you know
that guy sings it i i can't even i can't
even play piano man i don't know what
you're talking about
don't be shy now boys
every party needs some music wait
i used to be in a van i think i know the
one
follow my lead
[Music]
right son wrong key
after rescuing the hostages jtf officers
joined up with the second wave agents to
assist in the final fight against a
well-defended larry barrett
even in her last moments larae continued
to preach to her followers and show
maximum disrespect towards the
government and authorities
without larry the ruckus threat was
considerably reduced and in-house
fighting started they were forced into
hiding
it's clear how much an effect her death
had
the planning and ruthless leadership of
larry barrett would never be replaced
but the rikers were not down and out yet
the attack on the lexington event center
had forced them to retreat from the
fancy apartments they took over down to
the filthy conditions of the underground
the ruckers are continually looking for
payback against the jtf and the division
and this has been shown through
encounters like clear skies and a
massive attack that was launched on the
news agency and the stolen signal battle
after larae barrett's death the rikers
were in a state of disarray with a
constant barrage of new leaders
unsuccessfully attempting to pick up
where lorraine left off
dragoff would receive a visit by a
ruckus member who knew him from prison
you recognize me not really
rikers
you former inmate or
one of the new recruits i was two cells
over when you threw the wardens keys to
barrett hope you're not looking for a
handout nah ain't like that
i thought you'd like to hear about an
opportunity i'm listening barrett took a
bullet or ten
there's a lot of internal conflict so
not sure i'm the right guy just come by
and say hello i think you'll like us
we already owe you
unsure at first he decided to go and see
what he had to work with
and what he found was a group of
desperate people who simply wanted to
survive
he saw these people as his people
his family
i watched how this country responded to
calls from help from those in need
discarding them to come to the aid of
men with means we showed them
we stormed their castles
we took from them what they took from us
we threw those rich bastards out of
their penthouses and we built something
from the ruins
a community
no
a family
god be proud
family first millen cliff
well he taught me a lot
but not that he meant to i watched as he
bent meant to his will
how he corrupted people around him
changing good to bad
the innocent to guilty
the family he built
was one of crime
of extortion
of bribery
of murder i
chose the law
and all i saw was a different side of
the same coin
police corrupt thugs taking petty bribes
division
delusional killers of the highest order
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
you
yeah
you're criminals
i am too we all are
but you didn't deserve what they did to
you
so now
we'll take what we can
it's time to ring in a new era
dragoff was able to bring the rikers
crew together the in-house fighting was
stopped
under his guidance they had structure
and they were carving out a territory
that they could call home
after months of babysitting the rich
dragoff had gone full circle and was
taking from them in order to build up
supplies for his new family
the riker ranks were starting to swell
from the joining of local gangs and
desperate families who were struggling
to survive alone
with the rikers they had security food
and supplies to last them a lifetime
after being left for dead on the prison
island things were starting to look
pretty good
but dragoff's successes were starting to
get recognised outside of the group
and eventually he received a visit from
a certain rogue agent
aaron keener
i'm gonna need a list here you go
some of these are gonna be hard to find
sarah crates aren't so bad
these specialized chemicals and viral
cultures though
they'll take some time i'm patient
but
i'm job number one
unless you want to start experiencing
staff loss [ __ ] you keener
these people are family just think of me
as a second cousin if that makes it
easier
i won't and it doesn't but i'll get the
[ __ ] on your list with the condition
that you leave us alone loaded at the
pier
i'll give times and locations for
deliveries
don't worry
i'll make it worth your while
dragoff wasn't all that interested in
working with kina but understands the
value in keeping on his good side
but in saying that perhaps he took too
long or maybe kina just wanted to show
what he was capable of
everyone shut the [ __ ] up you may have
heard rumblings after the bloodbath in
midtown
yeah
it's true we lost a lot of good people
people i consider family what the [ __ ]
happened
peter happened
and unless we play ball he'll keep
happening [ __ ] that guy let's kill him
shut the [ __ ] up ron
i don't like this any more than you
but this
is an opportunity for us
and it'll keep us in the good graces of
a powerful ally first things first
we're moving downtown
we're gonna take an enclave in the heart
of the financial district itself
what's an enclave god damn it ron shut
the [ __ ] up
dragov and the rikers proceeded to storm
wall street
they shifted their entire operation down
to lower manhattan
again taking from the rich and
stockpiling vast amounts of food weapons
body armor and ammunition
he was able to set up his black market
operations where people who had the
resources to trade could visit
this would also help with acquiring some
of the more unusual pieces from kena's
list
however kino was starting to grow
impatient
was i unclear don't patronize me keener
i'm honestly asking because you still
haven't delivered you realize that
moving our entire operation south takes
time don't you do i look like a man who
cares about your problems
i care about one thing the delivery of
the supplies i asked for you'll get them
this [ __ ] is hard to find you got 24
hours
if i don't get a delivery by then i'll
make what happened to heavy look
downright pleasant compared to the rest
of your crew wait
what the [ __ ] did you do to heavy i'm
sure you'll figure it out
don't make me come back
keena's list included biohazard
materials and items that would require
chemists to prepare
because of this he wasn't able to
complete his order on time
as punishment kenya killed the ruckus
member heavy and told dragoff that he
would continue eliminating ruckus
members if he didn't deliver
reluctantly dragoff complied and helped
kina with various other tasks for the
sake of his new family
keena ordered dragoff along with fellow
rogue agents vivian conley javier kajika
and theo parnell to assault the jtf base
of operations in lower manhattan
he assisted in taking out the jtf guards
on site while conley planted kina's new
bio weapon
division agents arrived from washington
dc and investigated the attack
while there they found evidence pointing
directly towards james drago along with
his fellow rogue agent co-conspirators
which proved they were the ones behind
the attacks
over the course of time dragoff was
tracked down and was found to be
residing in the financial district where
he was running his black market
operation
in an attempt to retrieve kina's
supplies the division stormed the
district
they were met by duchess and a group of
rikers
the division dealt with duchess and the
rikers and proceeded to claim the
supplies
pushing through the rucker defenses the
division managed to destroy the apc
and made it to the stock exchange
building where dragoff was waiting
the division fought on and killed
dragoff as well as two of his
lieutenants
[Music]
many hostile factions rose to power
after the outbreak using the devastation
and lawlessness to quickly gain power
and territory
the ruckus started as one of the most
straightforward factions in the division
with these guys what you saw is what you
got
there was no hidden agendas within this
group
they simply wanted to create chaos in
the wake of the outbreak but then
dragoff was introduced
i feel this was a bit of a sad story
he removed himself from the situation
where he'd grown up surrounded by crime
and murder to instead do good
only to find himself in a setting that
was surrounded by the corruption of the
police force
still he fought on to put an end to it
and made a name for himself to the point
of being recruited by the division
but yet again in his eyes he was placed
in a position where the elites of
society were given preference over
everyone else
what happened on riker's island caused
him to snap
obviously in search from a young age for
a group that he could call family
he found what he was looking for in the
rikers
he was attempting to lead them down a
robin hood sort of path and giving to
the ones left helpless and abandoned by
the government
and from what we can tell from the comms
he actually seemed to be straightening
the rikers out to a certain extent
but of course then keener comes into the
picture
and by killing and threatening his new
family dragoff was forced down a path
that would ultimately lead to his death
what are your thoughts on dragoff i
actually quite like the extra depth that
the warlords of new york brought to the
rikers story
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
uh
[Music]